-Guys, do you ever see
a photo in the news
and you think that headline
should be different?
We're gonna take care of that
right now.
It's time for
"News and Improved."
Here we go.
-♪ News and Improved ♪
-For example,
check out this first photo.
The original headline was...
That headline
can definitely be improved
because if you only looked
at the photo,
the headline could have been...
It's like...
[ Applause ]
Up next, this headline says...
But the headline
could have been...
[ Applause ]
-"What?!"
-The next headline was...
The headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
I would see that.
I would see that tomorrow.
[ Steve laughs ]
Next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
"Fierce"?
[ Laughs ]
Next headline was...
[ Audience cheers ]
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
This next headline was...
Headline could have been...
[ Applause ]
The next headline was...
Headline could have been...
"Huh? Huh? Huh?"
[ Applause ]
And finally,
this headline was...
Headline could have been...
That's all the time we have
for "News and Improved."